all right i'm gonna show you one of my
games now
you know
yeah almost
it's gonna be almost as interesting
but but it wasn't a great game my game
it wasn't as clean as lavon's but it had
an interesting moment that i think is
perfect for
for calculation so anyway i was playing
with black
we're gonna go through the opening
pretty quickly
yeah pretty
mainline
french
uh this line has become quite popular
recently it's one of those long forcing
lines
you've never seen it
do you usually play knight c3 against
the french
that's probably why
yeah i mean the french is a tricky
oh the exchange
i love the advanced i played it i played
it last week at the spring classic okay
i think it's a great opening
the exchange can be pretty pretty spicy
too if you if you if you want to yeah
um i'm guessing you don't want to though
nothing wrong with that but uh yeah the
exchange for example um
yes
i remember i was playing this move for a
while which is kind of interesting
um then this is pretty sharp too
that's
yeah so i mean
i i think the exchange french is one of
the most underrated
openings and i think it's actually very
good
you should check out
this book
um
by alex fishbein
alex fishbein is a grandmaster from
at least now he lives in new jersey
who plays these
offbeat openings that are now all of a
sudden becoming popular so he's starting
to publish books on those openings and
uh he's always played the exchange
french and he
just wins like every game i'm like
this is supposed to be like a boring
opening
where you you maybe get a draw or
something but but he wins all the time
and his book is really interesting he
talks about a lot of cool lines
um and certainly black's not expecting
it so you're going to catch a lot of
people off guard anyway here we went for
some pretty mainline stuff
i'm going to go through it real quick i
don't want to get
bogged down here
i am black
and um
uh so anyway after queen d8 i think this
is our first
key moment of the game it's it's not
really a calculation moment but at least
we're going to understand what this game
is about
black has a better pawn structure
has the bishop pair
but is momentarily behind in the
development right so
this king is kind of nervous about
staying in the center and it would like
nothing more than to get to the king's
side
and
that's going to happen probably after a
move like bishop c5 right and castle
king's side
if black manages to accomplish this
then white's going to have some pretty
serious problems along the c file
because the pawn on b2 is missing so
that makes the knight on c3 unstable and
the pawn on c2 weak
so so this is black's plan bishop c5 and
castles if black gets this black is
doing really well
what is white going to try to do
um
f5 is
is going to be a fundamental piece of
the puzzle but again what you want to do
when you see a move
you want to sort of decorate it with
other moves that can sort of help out
right so so f5 is the center piece
but it's not the only move it's not like
you just play f5 and the game is over
oh no
that's good but that's a good start you
have to
keep going
yeah this happens
quite often it's an interesting idea it
kind of shifts the focus from the king
side to the queen side though
um which is not a bad thing
so this is a possibility
what else what other moves would be
useful for what
i was gonna say uh
there should be six plus one
bishop b6 this is actually something
that black always needs to be very
careful with but right now there's no
why not what is blind
you just go to uh
you go to uh
i just came from e7 right
yeah
i'm not repeating moves uh
i'm inter if i go queen e7 then i can't
go bishop c5 and castles it messes up my
whole thing
yes right so this is the key move bishop
c5 anyway yeah so that way i i check you
and i get rid of this bishop just in
time
and it's perfect right i'm ready to
castle so so black's doing well there
so
taking that line into consideration you
could see how maybe a move like king h1
would be useful queen e3 stopping bishop
c5 so you can actually take some
precautions here these are these are all
useful moves for white queen e3 king h1
i think queen e3 right now is considered
to be the best move
um anyway my opponent played king h1
i played bishop c5
he took
and played f5
right so you got it
so white's really coming at me now
how am i going to deal with this i mean
let's say let's say i were to castle
right what would be the most
direct or
simple uh
way to put this game forward
and if i go like g6
uh you just bring your queen down to
mate right yeah game over so that that's
a good example of how things can spin
out of control for black right so we
never want to allow a pawn to get to f6
because then the game is just going to
be over
so what do we do if you take your king
it's over anyway
you're doing it again
if you take it's over anyway
no no i mean i thought when you said if
you take right you take here oh oh i'm
sorry you're saying after castle's f6
oh if i take here
oh i see i see i'm sorry
yeah yeah
so i don't know i mean let's say
just take back one takes
king h8
and then you go here
right
so how do we do this
queen h6
right away or no uh i'm sorry take first
so take here
but then he goes the same right here
um
then
uh
okay try to kick you out
here or here
all right
and um
does your king
i think my king is feeling pretty safe
with this rook on g6 all right i could
always just go h6 if you if you go rook
h3
and also i might take this pawn i don't
know maybe i'll go like bishop here
take here this is starting to look like
we're hitting a wall yeah
so i'm thinking
what if i go here first right the move
that you suggested
your subconscious was telling you the
right move
so if you take the knight then i take
here and you didn't get to play king h8
rook g8 in time
if he takes the pawn then i can do this
rook f3 and rook g3 idea so the real
question is well what happens if i go
here
so notice how
once you have the pieces of the puzzle
you can you can move them around right
you don't you shouldn't take for granted
what the right move order is going to be
usually you assume that it's going to be
something and that's the main blockage
you have right you're like okay but i go
f6 e takes f6 queen h6 rook f3 but i'm
not getting there right and you're like
but it has to be that way it doesn't
have to be that way right those have to
be the moves but they don't have to be
played in that order
so here queen h6 is just crushing so
the moral of the story is if you see a
pawn on f6 something has gone terribly
wrong
a great question that's what i was going
to ask you what would you do instead of
castling
well never mind what you're supposed to
do
but
what what can you do
to stop white's
attack
queen a5
okay let's see
do i have rook b8
bishop takes and f6
actually maybe there you can just take
and go rook g8 that doesn't look so
clear so maybe after queen a5 what if i
go f takes e6
if bishop takes i want to go queen g5
oh but then you castle right so we're
just looking at this
yeah right so here
yeah you take i assume right sure yeah
and now here okay
right but the point is you can't take
the knight because i'm threatening mate
i'm threatening this pawn right but then
you do castles
yeah now it looks like you're in good
shape
so this is not a big deal
so
do i have
anything else besides queen g5 i don't
think so right you're good to go
i don't know looks kind of scary but i
don't know if
it's that scary
um what if i
cut my losses
so
well if you cancel then i get to play my
idea right
this thing
the question is if i if you take
what's going to happen here
right rook f8
and then you're uh you just take the
bomb
yeah this looks this looks really scary
right because you can't go bishop takes
you can't go pawn takes i'm about to
take on f7 i think this should be this
should be crushing right
so
so after f5 we're in a real conundrum
here all right we can't castle we can't
go queen a5 what are the other options
that looks pretty nice
actually a pretty interesting move it's
it's a thematic move in these positions
it makes sense because you know your
entire counter play is based on
uh pressure along the c file
so so this could be interesting but in
general
if you want to make your life easy if
you play the french defense
the moment that white puts a pawn on f5
you just snatch it right off right
um
of course
well that's the point you want to play
positions that look terrible but aren't
terrible right because then your
opponent is like oh this must be
terrible for him it's not so much
now
after knight takes d5 i would really
like to castle
right if i can castle and play bishop e6
i think i'm probably a lot better here
so what should i do
okay so after black castles what can
white do
oh yeah
you could also even consider this move
but let's start with castles which seems
like the most natural move
i guess you can do some tricks
yes sir
yeah i think yeah i think you've you've
tapped into
the lifeblood of that position
because once you cancel it
and then start bringing the cleaning
yeah well the thing about the position
after castles is that
without a without a pawn on f6 it's a
lot harder
for white to deliver a mating attack
so you know that idea
might be
a little bit far away but there's
something else in black's position
that's
that's quite loose
yeah and here in the chat they're
pointing out
rook takes d7 right and after queen
takes there's that night check that you
were talking about you don't want to
throw the check in right away because
then you would
you wouldn't really be winning anything
i mean you would probably still be
winning the game
right it looks promising but rook takes
d7 is just like lights out
so we can't castle unfortunately so
in order to castle we have to move the
bishop
c6 okay so how does the game continue
after bishop c6
uh
how does it how do you win the road
knight f6 what do you mean queen takes
okay
i mean the first thing i would look at
here is
c7
okay
king asked about a
d7 yeah
and then that's pretty well then there
are discovery possibilities
there aren't that many good discoveries
there though because your rook is
hanging right so
that's true
but after c7 king e7 white has a
devastating move
oh
is it is queen
queen g5 yeah right after queen g5 is
over the king has to stay close to the
queen
check and now if king d7
yeah just work d1 right and this is over
and if f6 i think this is just checkmate
so
so castles is out bishop c6 is out
because now you don't have knight c7
right the bishop's not interfering with
my rook on c5 so my rook's controlling
the c7 square
and that check doesn't really do
anything
well
otherwise what do you do with white
because i'm threatening your knight and
i'm threatening to castle
two fairly serious threats
okay but um what about your knight like
if you go rook f fb1 i can go rook takes
d5
okay
but let's say if you go here
i mean i don't know maybe i can take
this pawn but let's let's just keep it
simple let's say castle
just too anxious to castle
there's a pawn there
yeah i mean here i'm threatening rook
takes i'm threatening bishop tags uh
generally speaking once black manages to
castle black is out of the woods
so white better have something here
can't move the night
we agree
in the chat somebody's suggesting the
move queen b4 it's kind of an
interesting idea
the point is that after rook takes then
i have
rook b8 but it's not that clear right
because i also have bishop c8 here not
to mention
that i could also
take with the queen
on d5 and after here
then i could go bishop c8 as well right
so
this is another move which you might get
excited at first
and then you'll be like oh it doesn't
work but it doesn't mean you should
forget about it right it's queen before
is going to be a piece of the puzzle
you've seen an idea
but
by itself it's not going to get you
anywhere you need to
make it part of something larger
how can we make queen before stronger
can you do that sequencing yeah
so queen b4 yeah queen takes
okay so
uh okay you can go back
so i i've been looking at
rookie seven okay and after king f8
that maybe
right now it's a much stronger move
because we're x-raying this king so for
example
let's start with the obvious moves right
like what happens if queen takes d5
take the knight i'm threatening
all right can't stop
i always i always have rook ca right
or bishop c8
or king takes rook for that matter
yeah so actually here in the chat
somebody mentioned
rook c7 right and now you're going to
win the exchange and most importantly
well maybe just as importantly you
prevented black from doing
what he needs to do which is castle
right so now your brook's messed up your
king's messed up and you're going to
lose in exchange
that's game
so
um
queen takes d5 is out
what about rook takes d5 this one should
be even easier
you just wipe that's just
yeah right just rook d7 and that's game
over
um
all right all right
what about
bishop takes d5
okay
so what's going on in this position this
is
just
chaos
well
who's better who's we oh i think fights
white's better why is white better
because of black goes
okay
you have activity what what is that
activity about like what like
i mean our work is
making a threat right
now um
so let's say black
uh okay okay yeah i tend to think i
guess black might play g6 and then
um
well actually this position after g6
i don't know if i can get to play bishop
king g7 in rookie eight i'm feeling
pretty good
here okay and let's say i take
and now i bring my king over
and then you bring the other palm out
okay
and
here
or maybe maybe i should do it with the
king
right you have to defend it i suppose
so these pawns are pretty untouchable
that's true
but i don't know
maybe i am
maybe i am worse here
what if i what if i do this
i don't know i think black might be okay
here let's let's just take a quick look
uh um yeah it says about about equal so
so black is holding on but that's an
interesting idea queen d6
um it does give white some winning
chances for sure
black has
an even better move here
i think yeah
huh
black is better
yes
wait it's black's move
yeah
right we're just talking about queen
takes queen takes g6 queen d6 right so
we're trying to improve for black
yeah there we go so bishop takes g2 king
takes
and now queen takes
right so
now if you go something like check
queen eight queen takes f5
again it looks like white has some
interesting piece activity and pressure
but black has a way of just solving all
the problems here i i completely missed
this during the game though um
hopefully i would have found it but how
black to play and
equalize
where does the queen go
queen tags
oh no no no
but that's the idea
move the king over
looks a little scary
maybe not so bad actually
rook c1
yeah this could be interesting
um
now but black has this very nasty check
on c6
because if you go king g1 now i just
trade off the queens with the queen g6
uh
you mean in this line after king g8 c4
well i don't know do you
do you really want that let's say i go
here
i guess i guess you could try to get
away with it
because it defends f7 just in time
yeah
maybe you're right
so maybe c4 is not the move
maybe i should do some kind of
i don't know like like rook d1
at least stopping this
i mean i think
i think we want to play the check
instead of moving
yeah right um the nice thing about this
check is that it gets the queens off the
board and that pretty much relieves all
the pressure
because uh if rook f3
i just go queen g6 anyway you don't have
any good
moves to stop queen g6 so anyway
that's kind of um
what i saw during the game i actually
saw
i was going to play queen takes and then
g6 and just
i thought that was that was fine
but then
out of the corner of my eye
i saw a move that was too tempting to
resist
and i played it almost immediately play
queen a5
this turns out to be a blunder and
it's
not quite losing like i don't have to
resign but i have to make some
pretty accurate only moves
basically
my idea was
that
i want to go g5 king g7 that's my plan
if i can get my king to g7 everything is
forgiven
right
for example
one line i i saw that i thought was kind
of funny
was rook d7
if you take my queen i checkmate you
if you take my rook
i checkmate you
right because now you go here i go here
and now i have
a very nice version of philidor's mate
yeah it's mother right
so
rook d7 looked kind of cool
but after g5 all of a sudden you don't
have any good moves and my next move is
king g7
so that was the original idea and it was
just like when i saw it i was like this
is too too much fun to not play it
another idea was well let's say
white like trades the rooks and uh and
moves the rook away
threatening a check in the back ring i
can't can't take the knight yet because
of check but again g5 saves the day
and king g7 is coming and then white's
position is just falling apart
oops i messed that up
uh where did we go
here we go
queen b8 was another idea
but this didn't really
create too many problems for me because
after rook c8 queen d6 it looks like i'm
getting set up for some devastating
discoveries but i can go queen takes d5
just in time
and after takes takes takes king e7
this is already the worst is over for
black
so it seemed like everything was holding
up
um
the rook move doesn't work the check
doesn't work the trade doesn't work
there was one idea that i missed
and it's actually very interesting how
this move
all of a sudden makes all of the ideas
that we just saw all of these ideas that
don't work for white with this move they
all come together and work perfectly
uh it's white to move
yeah
is it just a
full challenges broken is that a roof
right rook to c7 has the problem that i
can trade queens first
right
and after this i just take your rook
so i can unpin pretty easily
so this is white's attacking team
right these are the pieces that are
going to checkmate the black king in
theory
but for the moment this black king
enjoys the shelter
of some very committed
pawns
so it's hard to really come at this king
unless you
you rip it from its shelter of pawns
think of the aronian game that we just
looked at right
he completely decimated black's gnh
pawns and then he was able to access the
king
so in order to attack this king it needs
to be brought out into the open
somebody in the chat is suggesting
knight c7 nice blitz move because if i
take then you mate me
but unfortunately i think i'll take this
piece instead
and that's it
so it's not knight c7 either
rook takes e6
maybe again i can throw in this queen
trade
all right because i don't think you have
any checks and after you take
then i take
you
getting warmer
where's that
uh
so if bishop takes
then uh i check organ
so check i have to go here
oh then you bring your rook in the park
yeah you got it bam and that's over nice
so now
all the pieces are participating in the
attack so let's say i go king takes
the same thing
to the seventh check
okay
and uh if i go here
oh uh yeah okay
what was that
and uh
[Music]
here
or
or here i'll go here
oh no then you have knight c6
so i have to go king f8
all right now i go here
green b8
looks pretty scary yeah right so i i
guess because if i block here i think
you have this check right so i have to
block with the bishop
knight d6
if i go here
oh now you have a check here
right so so let's say can i can i do
this
let's do it
although you can fork the oh wait then
the works there oh you can still fork
him in the rook
where uh he went knight to
c
rex
right no the nice thing is that this is
not checkmate right
so that's kind of nice but maybe i don't
have to take on c oh yeah do it because
the queen's hanging yeah wait
so maybe i take
i'm up a piece right
it looks kind of questionable
right
and now maybe
check
this is the only check i have
that's kind of
crazy yeah and here
yeah
yeah because if you keep giving checks i
think i should be able to block them
right
that's funny i mean
this looks like an insane position i
wonder if it really this is crazy does
it like like it's like it's winning
after king takes e5 obviously
oh yeah
yeah yeah that's funny
so
i remember
seeing this during the game i didn't i
was not aware that black was winning i
thought okay
i'm just gonna get mated within the next
couple moves
but i didn't see the mate right i was
like okay kind of holding on
so white finds
a really brilliant move here
and uh i guess we're we're already into
our double x-clam
uh
class so is it all right if we just like
roll them both into one
might as well
uh
so white plays queen b8
which looks
which looks terrible right because
now after rook c8
your knight is hanging your queen is
hanging your rook is hanging
but now white can play rook takes f7
and after king takes
then queen b7 so the question is
how does forcing the rook
to come back to c8
change things
okay but compared to the variation we
just looked at right we were just
looking at king g8
why doesn't that same line work for
black and the other line black was
winning why is black losing now
if i go king g8
here here
that's right now you can take the rook
right you don't have to go into that
crazy line so that was the point so
white lured my rook to a vulnerable
square to make the entire line work now
why do i have to go
to g8 why can't i just go
king g6
okay i mean i'll go here
well if knight takes e6 i think i can
just go queen takes e5
i'm up in exchange and my king looks
safer than it ever looked so far in this
game
yeah this is the key move after queen f3
you're just getting mated right i'm
threatening queen h5 queen h3
and if g6 then you can take the bishop
not so much for taking the bishop's sake
but
you're still threatening checkmate right
so this is game over
i don't have queen takes e5 that's kind
of the key point
i did not i did not i did draw this game
i'm very proud to have drawn this game
especially
especially because of the defense that
black has here
so it's black to play
only move to save the game
uh
queen d7 that would that would be ideal
but
not possible
oh wait yeah
oh that my eyes are terrible
well we just looked at king ga right
runs into this fork we looked at king g6
runs into knight f4 queen f3
king e8 runs into checkmate in one move
king f8 runs into queen e7 check and
queen takes e6 so that's no good
so we're we're running out of bullets
man
only move
what
oh
come on trade queens man this would be
perfect now black is actually probably
much better here why did they just say
well that's what he did unfortunately
so
now he's got all these discoveries right
so so what's the follow-up
get rid of that pawn so that the king
can can find a new square a safer square
and he actually has um he has no good
discoveries here
he was incredibly low on time and i
think incredibly disappointed that he
didn't have a forced checkmate probably
that the best thing that he can do here
is
uh take
and then take this pawn
and play this position with an extra
pawn this actually is pretty going to be
pretty hard for white to win because the
pawns
are not um
connected
so they're very weak and
very hard to to move forward
so anyway this is like the
the worst
case scenario
he played
knight d5 and after here
here king f6
i was expecting him to take
and again he has an extra pawn and you
know plenty of pressure but
his main advantage is
the extra pawn and it's not an easy pawn
to to make use of
instead he saw an opportunity to take me
out
immediately
with queen b4 threatening rookie one and
rook takes e6 not to mention that if i
move my queen away there could be a
check
so
here i attacked
um
what do i do
yes i played rook b8 and now after queen
d2 he's renewed the idea of rookie one
so how would you guys play with black
another important defensive move
here
so where does the queen go
i mean my original idea was i got to get
my bishop out of here right maybe
something like bishop f7 but the problem
is after rookie one i don't have a lot
of good queen retreats right this queen
is coming in like if i
i don't know if i go like
queen b5 or something
this is starting to look like it's going
to be checkmate real soon
yeah
um
okay what about this
check
right it looks like my dark squares are
just falling apart here right rookie one
is coming this diagonal is going to be a
problem this diagonal can be a problem
this is looking pretty grim
so
what we need to do
is
focus zoom in on what our opponent is
trying to do how is he trying to beat us
and what move can we play
to take the teeth out of that thread
yes
um bishop takes a2
for
b1
excellent so now if rookie one actually
you have queen takes e1 and after queen
takes then rook b1
and this end game is completely losing
for white because you have the bishop
against the knight and the outside
passer an extra pawn that's it
so
so bishop takes a2 actually would be the
move even if there wasn't a white pawn
there you need to
hit white where it hurts which is his
back rank
so i think he missed bishop takes a2
and after this it's anybody's game
really um
i'm up a pawn but i still have some king
safety problems
uh he played
he played knight d3
and after queen d4 c3
queen d6 and now c4 right he's trying to
get
the queen
to this diagonal again so i played rook
b3
takes
takes and anyway this this game
eventually just fizzled out into a draw
all right
let's move on so you um
when you say you made a blunder the
earlier the engine wouldn't think so but
oh no the engine thinks so um back here
oh i thought you said you had some only
oh well i mean it's technically a
blunder because i have to go into that
position with like where i'm down upon
and i have to deal with all these
discoveries
um yeah if he had just taken my bishop
or whatever but if you compare that
to this position
i mean
you can't you can't even compare them
right i don't have to jump through any
hoops here as black and my my play is
pretty straightforward not to mention i
have that bishop takes g2 move
so
after what after you're blood
after queen a5
plus one not so bad
i was i thought it was like plus seven
or something ridiculous like that but no
yeah he he has to find this very
accurate sequence
so that's what i mean it's kind of like
practically it's
it's
it's especially it wonders um
practically speaking right because you
have
maybe the engine doesn't think it's
practically i don't know i think the
engine thing is a pretty big mistake
because look at the the difference right
bishop takes d5 is zero zero
between a5 is plus one really okay so
i
whatever the definition of blunder is uh
accuracy
yeah but the thing is it's not just like
the objective values like i'm the only
one that that has to make hard moves
there right so that's the that's the
point
it's bad any way you look at it because
not only is it like if i make all the
only moves
my prize is
white is plus one
right and the other line i make obvious
moves and it's zero zero so that's why
it's a blunder because it's just a bad
decision
so
anyway let's move on to another game
um
which one shall i show you next
this was this was a a good one i think
okay so let's go through the opening
fairly quickly
i'm playing with white
pretty standard nimzo indian
and uh
after f3 i don't know does anybody play
queen pawn or nimzo indian
yeah what do you
like
so what do you do against the nimzo
indian you go
okay queen c2 yeah that's all the rage
right now
i'm starting to look more and more into
these structures where
where white embraces the doubled pawns
because everybody thinks this is bad for
white
i'm not sure it's so easy it's kind of
like
the
the the general perception of the
isolated queen pawn right that everybody
thought it was bad and now all of a
sudden like it's amazing
so
i have a newfound appreciation for pawn
weaknesses because
i always like to say that
upon weaknesses and peace activity are
like two sides of the same coin or
or sit on opposite ends of a scale right
there they are inversely proportional
like when your pawn structure is
terrible
your piece activity usually is very good
when your pawn structure is
immaculate usually you have passive
pieces so
having a terrible pawn structure doesn't
really mean you have a terrible position
it actually creates this huge potential
for your pieces to become active
in this line for example white's idea
white has a pretty clear sketch of where
the pieces go that's what i like about
it white wants to get a pawn to e5
a bishop to d3
maybe knight to h3 the bishop can come
to g5
you want to castle maybe go f4 f5 right
that's just a general outline
so
in this game black decided he didn't
want anything to do with this and
offers me to undouble my pawns so now
i'm getting rid of like what's supposed
to be wrong about my position
and i get to keep my dark square bishop
[Music]
and now d takes c5
does anybody recognize this position
it's actually very
very topical these days
it usually arises
from a different variation of the nimzo
indian
which is really the popular variation
which is the f3 line
um this is probably the most aggressive
way that you can play against the nimzo
indian but it's very closely related to
a3 and to e3
these three moves i would say
are members of the same family because
the kinds of positions that you get
are very similar
so usually after f3
d5 a3 takes takes
c5 takes takes and takes we get the same
position
that i got in my game
so after d takes c5 i remember seeing
some amazing games i think there's a
there's an anon game
that's particularly impressive
where usually black goes queen a5 and
after e4 knight f6
bishop e3
something like castles queen b3
the game goes on
and
black is just always so close to solving
all the problems but white keeps finding
you know these these little
uh hurdles for black to jump over so
anyway i think those positions are
fascinating i was totally cool
going in over that um going into that
but my opponent surprised me and played
this move f5
what do you think the idea of f5 is
right
um
is this
is this bad for white well
i'm threatening your queen but i'm also
threatening your pawn on d4 right so
yeah so your your position is falling
like a house of cards here uh right
because you move the queen
now maybe queen takes d4
and you lost two paws that's fine
so
white's idea is not so much to defend
the pawn on c3
but
hopefully to sort of make a trade white
doesn't care about this pawn in fact
white would like to get rid of this pawn
if you were to play something like
knight takes after takes takes and
bishop b2 you can see the advantage
of having no pawn on c3 because your
your dark square bishop is amazing
and and that's the idea of the entire
line the whole point of the f3 or a3
variations is to say
this bishop is going to win the game
right my dark square your dark square
weaknesses are going to be
sort of your undoing
so black has to be very careful about
that
and the reason that black plays
f5 is to ensure the stability of the
knight on d5 for example i can't go e4
because after takes takes queen h4
i'm just losing my pawn
so
i played knight h3 the idea is that now
i'm renewing the idea of e4 because
after takes takes queen h4 i have knight
f2 defending my e4 pawn
so now he goes queen a5
i go e4
and after takes takes
can't take on c3 because of bishop d2
hitting the queen and the knight
so he goes knight f6
now c3 is hanging c5 is hanging e4 is
hanging
which one do you defend
c3 yc3
but remember that
out of all the pawns that's the least
valuable because it's the one that
interferes with our bishop the most
right if we wanted to put a bishop here
that pawn would bother us yep
okay
so
how do you defend it
you push it yeah
but now i now i might take on c3 more
than anything because then i can take on
e5
again
killed two birds with one stone
so it's actually a trick question you
don't defend either of them
right
you don't you don't care about either
one of these three pawns
if you if it were up to white just wipe
him off the board
but let it
consume tempe for black
right now after queen takes c5
for example if knight takes e4
i think here i can just castle
and my lead in development
my dark square bishop is going to make
up for my missing pawns right something
like this can already see
black just basically getting getting
crushed here
queen f7 is coming
i don't know i'm sure there's many ways
of playing this
but queen takes c5 is an interesting
move because it stops me from castling
so it kind of halts me on my tracks and
says
stop this development right for a moment
so this is a this is a key moment in the
game how would you guys play as white
knight f2 to me this is the probably the
move that made the most sense right and
if castles
castle and let's say i take this
do what
your night is pinned
yeah um
i don't know maybe here you could
prepare this a little bit with queen d3
cover these pawns
and then castle i was looking at this
position this is probably fine
for white but it felt like i was having
to make these defensive moves like queen
d3 and defending my ugly pawns you
should never be
if you're gonna take on a bad pawn
structure
your most valuable pieces should never
have to waste time and energy defending
them
so right here
okay that's interesting
because well this pawn is always hanging
right so let's say i just go here
yeah because if bishop a3
takes and we usually want to meet queen
take c3 with bishop d2
i didn't like i didn't like the
direction that the game was going in
right it felt like um retreat
passive
you know
i was losing momentum
what i wanted to do was obviously i
wanted to castle
i wanted to bring my knight into the
game
i wanted to bring my bishop into the
game as well
but
this queen i mean black hasn't moved a
lot of pieces but this queen is really
causing me a headache
so
what do you do with your opponent's
good pieces
you trade them off right that's
that's the
the essence of peace trades and peace
trades is one of the most misunderstood
tools at your disposal in chess i hear
these things and i used to live by this
when i was a kid and then i realized
this is ridiculous like
when do you trade pieces when you're up
material right that's like the worst
reason to trade pieces it has nothing to
do
with material
when you are considering a peace trade
the basic question you need to ask
yourself is
is the piece
that i'm about to trade off is my piece
worse than my opponents
that's it
you can break down every piece trade to
that very simple question
um
a more advanced or sort of sophisticated
way of looking at peace trades is to say
well
let's say
that
just for argument's sake
that this
is a bad piece for black right
that's black's worst piece
another way you can use peace traits is
to isolate problems in your opponent's
position so for example
if the bishop on seat is the worst piece
what i'm interested in doing is trading
off all the good pieces
because those pieces pick up the slack
for the misplaced piece or bad piece so
what you do as you start taking pieces
off the board is you start amplifying
the problem
right so these are the the two ways of
thinking about peace trades you either
trade off your bad pieces for your
opponent's good pieces or
you start
taking pieces off the board to amplify a
specific problem so here the key move is
queen d4
because after queen d4 the queens come
off okay black takes my pawn
but now i'm able to do
all of the moves that i want i'm going
to play knight f4
i'm going to play
bishop c4 i'm going to play bishop b2
rookie 1 and d5 notice how
once i got those queens off the board
it's like the floodgates open like my
position just flows very easily
so
now the knight went back to f6
knight f4 knight c6
and this is an interesting calculation
moment
according to the sketch
that we just drew
right we want to play moves like bishop
c4 bishop b2 rook ae1 so now what we
need to do is figure out the order in
which the pieces of the puzzle go
of course if we play bishop c4 we have
to consider the move knight takes d4
so what would you guys
do do we spend a tempo with bishop b2
protect the pawn and then go bishop c4
or do we just floor it
so
after bishop c4 what's your idea if i
take this pawn
[Music]
okay so bishop b2
and let's say
i hit your rook
oh yeah
just went kool-aid guy on here
oh yeah
so even if i don't fork your two rooks
like if you go rook c1 i'm still gonna
fork your rook and bishop right and if i
can get this bishop off the board
that's the jackpot
but there's more to it
huh
so here and here
how do you sack the rook
that's right i want to be very careful
about trades
this is actually a key
key moment
[Music]
if if i go rook fe1 then you just go
knight take c4
and black's gonna castle or go bishop d7
that's
and if knight takes f1
um
then
rotates
so this is this is kind of an
interesting question right after knight
takes f1
should you take with the rook on c8 or
the bishop
the difference between these two moves
is
that if you take with the bishop you
don't trade rooks if you take with the
rook you do right so going back to our
our discussion on peace trades
who benefits from this trade whose piece
whose rook is better
obviously white's rook is better right
this rook is much more active this work
on a8 is doing nothing so the move is
bishop takes c8
and let's say the knight makes a run for
it
sorry could you i mean could you argue
about the bishop was better also
but i guess
what the bishop's gone in any case
right so i mean
because the option is
this position with rooks on a8 and c1 or
without
you keep the bishop
the bishop's going to c8 in any case
so the difference is that now you're
left with an active rook and black's
left with a passive broken and that
that's what you need to look for when
you're thinking about trades right like
what are you leaving on the board and
what are you taking out
so let's say the knight makes a run for
it
what's that
okay but now i take this guy
all right and what's uh after the dust
has settled what's going on here
uh i would say a whole lot of something
just not what you were hoping it was
right because black is probably winning
here black's going to bring the other
rook to e8 the other rook to c2 so
bad news
we don't want to let black off the hook
so easily
black
really the essence of black's position
what's going to make or break black is
whether black can can connect this rook
into the game
yeah the bishop just comes back to e6
and now the knight's in trouble
it dominates the knight we can also
prepare rook c7 right maybe wipe out
black's pawns
so black is in big trouble here
that's why after bishop takes c6 he took
on e6 right away
so his idea is if knight takes e6
now knight takes f1
and
it might look very tempting right knight
takes g7
king f7
rook c7 king g6 but that's as far as i'm
gonna go right white's gonna
maybe take here but white's still down
in exchange and most importantly what
happened the rook joins the game i can
play like rook c8 or whatever
so so black is again on top
so what's the move
what was that
oh oh it's in the background okay
excellent
so now you're gonna get your piece back
no matter what
you avoid losing the exchange and most
importantly you've delayed black's
intentions of connecting the rook so
black played knight d5
and now
i think knight takes e6 simply allows
king f7
right and the king if it gets in trouble
can go to g6
the rooks are coming in
so i played rook takes e6 and after king
f7 it looks like it
it all went down the tubes right black
connected the rooks
ready to play rookie eight
i'm down
upon
i better have something
so how should white play
watch out there's a knight controlling
that square
yeah
they changed the rules
but
you've actually
hit the nail on the head in terms of the
idea because we would love to put a rook
on c7
because it would push the king back
right the king
would have to go to one of these squares
because g6 is under control by our
knight
so the question is how can we
how can we make that happen
bishop i guess
bishop takes
bishop takes f6 so your idea is that
after knight takes
and let's say the king goes here
or actually i don't know if that's maybe
maybe here is better so i can defend
this if i need to i don't know
yeah i mean this looks crushing right
i'm only down to pawn but knight's
coming in rook's coming in i can take
these pawns anytime i want
all right so so that would be fantastic
but what happens
if well let's start with this one what
if i take this piece
now i'm hitting the rook
as well as the bishop
all of a sudden suddenly it seems like
there's a short circuit right in white's
in white's plans
the same thing goes i think i could even
get away with this
right because now the knight hangs and
the rook hangs too
so
bishop takes f6 would have been
wonderful but
it doesn't quite work
okay but but this just seems to play
into black's hand right black just wants
to get those rooks out
but let's not give up on our idea of
getting a rook to c7
so how else can we try to deflect that
knight on d5
we tried with bishop takes f6
okay
rook takes f6 because if i go pawn takes
then you just take this
and the f6 is gone and that's losing so
i have to go knight takes f6
and now i can finally bring my rook to
c7 and push the king back
right
um
where should the king retreat
he's got three options
you're saying king here
yeah
fair enough everybody
agree what happens if if
king away from the center
i do yeah that's a bummer
but maybe black is hoping to play like
you know h5 and rook h6
in the chat they're suggesting the move
96 which looks devastating threatening
checkmate
but all of a sudden after 98
not only am i defending g7 but i'm also
attacking your rook
and let's say if you go here then i'll
go h5 and rook h6
and again it's anybody's game
so how can we improve upon that
idea
doesn't have to be hard
right
just to remove the defender and now
there's no stopping rook g7 in fact this
is what happened in my game my opponent
played rookie and i just made it him
so
it's funny how
you know i identified this strategy
right or or what my opponent really
wanted to do he wanted to bring this
rook into the game and i just threw all
of my pieces at him so that he wouldn't
be able to do this now
the funny thing is
well king f8 is probably just as bad
because now i get to play this with
check so the only move is king e8 you
were right
it looks scary though because you're
letting me take on g7
and it seems like
something terrible is going to happen
here
but actually after knight d7 there are
no good discoveries
and black's next move is rook f8 and
rook c8 and the rooks get into the game
during the game
i actually thought
that um
yes after rook takes knight d7 i thought
after knight d5 it was game over
because i'm threatening knight c7
forking the king and the rook but i'm
also threatening rook e7
taking the rook on h8 so i was like you
can't defend both rooks at the same time
what did i miss
all right but then i i take the knight
right
it doesn't quite solve your problems
this game was played last month by the
way
being asked in the chat so it's a fairly
new game
they're also suggesting castle queenside
but you've already moved your king like
eight times so that's not i saw that
happen in a real chess game in the
tournament dude movies came a bunch and
casual in this position and it won the
game pretty embarrassing that happened
to me once in the game too oh wow you
didn't call it you didn't bring like
no i did it i oh you did it yeah i
forgot
um i actually
i was playing with black right and uh
the a file opens up so i go i take my
rook from a8 and i go rook takes a1
and then i bring my rook back and then i
just castle queen side like like 10
moves later
yeah
and the guy didn't realize it either so
when i got home i tried to enter the
game and it's not letting me castle i'm
like oh man this program is glitching
again
and then it's like no man you move you
move that rook
you can't do that in chess i'm like oh
okay this means you did a second time
too huh this means you missed it the
second time that you moved your rope up
oh yeah no it was it was not my my
finest moment
um
anyway so
so how does black play here
only move to save the game
what happens if you do an illegal move
well
if it's a
you know regular time control over the
board game
they'll usually penalize you the first
time
they'll
take a put a couple minutes on your
opponent's clock it's really kind of a
slap on the wrist it's not much
then if you do it a second time they're
like
you didn't hear me the first time you're
not supposed to do that and then if you
do it a third time you lose the game i
think like two two strikes is enough
um but apparently you get three in blitz
you get two though so if and you're more
likely to make illegal moves during a
blitz game
yeah king d8 this is key move right
because now there's no knight c7 and
rookie 7 is in check so i missed this
simple move
after king d8 um
i think the engine gives this as like
zero zero zero yeah it's crazy
um
i was going to play on but i felt like
oh man you know i wasn't expecting this
like i i was i was looking at stuff like
h4 just trying to get my pawn up um
but anyway
this would have certainly made things a
lot messier uh tracy how are we doing
with time
all right okay guys so i guess um that's
it for today i hope that you
you enjoyed some of these games some of
them are you know ripped right out of
the headlines others i kind of dug up
from my obscure tournament games
but in any case um i thought these were
kind of interesting positions so
thanks for coming